there are plenty of sightseeing
highlights in Tehran but few are more
popular than go lyst on Pallas it's one
of the high points of any tourists visit
to Iran the country has long been
internationally isolated and so most
Europeans know little about it this
German group of travelers was surprised
at how hospitable Iranians were to thai
soup at deloitte a the people are great
really polite nice and attentive they
ask where I'm from offer me tea without
a schism I didn't have expectations and
they've been exceeded but often the
country has amazing history beautiful
natural landscapes and exceptionally
friendly people Iranians are really
open-minded and speak to you on the
street you never feel you're a stranger
or a guest Tehran is home to 15 million
people and tourism could be one of the
country's biggest opportunities now that
Iran is slowly returning to the
international fold many young Iranians
are very well educated many of them are
also unemployed travel agencies that
cater to a foreign clientele are
expecting demand to rise restaurants
hotels bus companies everyone is
counting on much more business the
moment tourism has been considered as a
development option for the country
because of the main economic reasons the
comet impacts of tourism in job creation
in foreign exchange revenues
mine's revenues for the people and the
government well all of them all together
has been created to use them as an area
that most of the people think that they
have to invest on now that the nuclear
deal has been finalized international
travel companies are adding Iran to
their catalogues again and Western
politicians are also visiting the
country their goal to lay the ground for
business deals